[Music]
do you know who Maui is only the
greatest demigod in all the Pacific
Islands with this magical fish hook
he slowed down the Sun pulled islands
out of the sea battle monsters and I
should know
I'm Maui let me do this please nothing
really
what's a demigod
each of the storm
for their mommy
for generations this peaceful island has
been home to our family but beyond our
ease a great danger is coming
legend tells of a hero who journey to
find that demigod Maui
and together
they must save us all
no and when when away
[Music]
Maui
demigod of the wind and ti0 of men what
it's actually Maui shapeshifter demigod
of the Windansea hero of men I interrupt
it from the top hero of men go impact
going on a mission with some little
girls is my canoe and you will journey
to different did not see that coming the
ocean is a friend of mine
first we've got to go through a whole
ocean of bad caca hora
kako what
they're kind of cute
got your back it's Maori time
oh really
blow dart and my butt cheek we're going
to the realm of monsters don't worry
it's a lot farther down than it looks
[Music]
it's time to put my stone on the
mountain
[Music]
okay well then head on back put that
stone up there
why aren't you trying to talk me out of
it you said that's what you wanted it is
when I die I'm going to come back as one
of these or I chose the wrong tattoo why
are you acting weird I'm the village
crazy lady that's my job if there's
something you want to tell me just tell
me is there something you want to tell
me is this something you want to hear
Maui
shapeshifter demigod of the wind and sea
I am one zero of men what what it's
actually Maui shapeshifter demigod of
the wind and sea hero of men I
interrupted from the top hero of men go
I sorry sorry sorry sorry and women men
and women both oh not a guy girl thing
odd you know now he is a hero to all
you're doing great what no I'm here too
of course of course yes yes yes yes now
he always has time for his fans when you
use a bird to write with
it's called tweeting yeah I know not
every day you get a chance to meet your
hero you are not my hero and I'm not
here so you can sign my or what has two
thumbs and pulled up the sky when you
were waddling yay hi this guy when the
night's got cold who stole you fire from
down below
look at that a note
Oh also I last so the son welcome to
stretch your days and bring you fun also
I harness the breeze you're welcome to
fill your sails and take your trees so
what can I say
you're welcome
for the island like open
there's no need
you're welcome ha I guess it's just my
way
you're welcome
you're welcome enjoy the island Maui
oh hey you're the one back the heart did
not see that coming
I am wanna of Mata Nui this is my canoe
and you will journey to different
alright get over it we got to move and
she's back hi the morn of Manu it was
Moana right yes
and you will restore the heart
[Music]
alright I'm out
oh come on we read the wind in the sky
when the Sun is high we sail the length
of the seas on the ocean reads at
nightly name of star
know where we are we know who we are we
said of course to find a brand new
island everywhere we're all
away away keep on
it's time to find home
Oh
or is reading every sign we tell stories
of our elders
window the way a boat
ah